avec nous et on reparle maintenant du
fameux syndrome de la guerre du golfe
cette maladie que des soldats auraient
contracté pendant les années 90 pendant
les opérations contre l'irak
une mission parlementaire française en
quête sur ce syndrome et mardi dernier
l'ancien commandant des forces
françaises dans le golfe le général rock
joffre a affirmé que les soldats
français avaient bien pris un médicament
contre les armes chimiques florent
muller soldats à présenter vos pilules
durant la guerre du golfe près de 9000
militaires français ont bien reçu
l'ordre de prendre des cachets de
pyridostigmine un médicament qui devait
les protéger d'une éventuelle menace
chimique irakienne une information
révélée mardi par l'ancien commandant
des forces françaises dans le golfe
le général michel robbe joffre devant la
mission parlementaire d'information
la grande muette est passé aux aveux
notre devoir explique l'officier était
de protéger les troupes
pourtant il ya encore deux mois le
ministre de la défense alain richard
tenait des propos bien différent pour
dans une interview reprise par
libération le 31 août dernier le
ministre affirmait que les soldats n'ont
pas reçu d'antidote préventif aux armes
chimiques alors qu un début de consensus
se dégage pour dire que ces produits
étaient dangereux en effet les
scientifiques américains s'accordent
aujourd'hui pour reconnaître la
dangerosité de ce médicament qui
entraîne des troubles neurologiques des
troubles précisément ressentie par
nombre d'anciens combattants français
les affirmations du général rob d'offres
constitue peut être un premier pas vers
la reconnaissance d'un syndrome du golfe
et de son indemnisation pour les membres
de l'association avigolfe d'autres
médicaments sont également en cause
il exige un bilan de santé pour les
vingt-cinq mille soldats français
envoyés dans cette guerre
amy